dallas caico doesn't get a lot of
attention but he can flat out pitch this
year his numbers are up a little bit era
is kind of elevated for him last year he
had a 199 run average for the season and
he's a guy that's going to elicit a lot
of soft contact he is the best at
throwing ground balls they'll turn a lot
of double plays behind him
the shet launches this ball into right
center field but it's playable for leori
garcia for route number two so buchette
gave it a ride but for a loud second out
one-two swing and a miss on a sinker to
strike him out toronto goes one two
three in the first tyunjin ryu faces the
white sox for the first time buck in his
big league career yeah it's kind of
surprising he's pitched a long time and
this is the first time he will start
against chicago this will be his 12th
start of the season
your mean mercedes hard hit to left
field and over the head of guerrielle
mercedes into second base gorilla
looked like a wind sock out there in
left field the sox will take the double
here's the cleanup man jose abreu one
for eight so far in the series
1-1 to abraham ripped into the right
field corner and the sox will take the
lead
jose a laser to right
and it's zip that's the start of a good
night mr stone
yasmani into right this is
two-run homer
just like that it's nothing
first pitch swinging
it was uh just laying in weight for one
to drive and it's three nothing white
socks
and now one up the middle panic will
play it on a bounce and on to first in
time as andrew vaughn is retired to
bring the inning to a close
but a rough start here tonight for the
blue jays if he's making his pitches and
the blue jays are over aggressive or
trying to pull everything he could have
himself a good night swinging a miss
strike three
second strikeout for kykel
one two holmes swinging a miss
on a cutter off the inside
kykel has faced six blue jays he's
retired all of them
kaiko this year actually is a reverse
split guy lefty's hitting him better
than righties not that unusual one and
two on panic the pits swinging a miss he
struck him out on a change-up so kykel
has a strikeout pitch working tonight he
has spanned four of the seven he's faced
strike three cut her inside five
strikeouts for dallas eight up eight
down
blue jays without a hit to this point a
stretch and a 2-1
on the ground to third charged by
moncada he'll throw to first and that'll
do it still no hits for the blue jays
mercedes pumps this ball to center field
on a 3-2 from ryu
i think mercedes has found a home in the
lineup against lefties in the two spot
mercedes at first one down
3-2 is there for strike three called
back door to the cutter two down two two
chain shop that abreu reaches for slow
roller to short simulator flips to panic
covering to force mercedes and the
inning is over the white sox will leave
a man on blue jays down three to nothing
at the end of three
[Music]
[Applause]
the shed in the air first base side
abreu over the shoulder
wow
look it's a great catch but that's an
easier play for danny
that it is for jose
he's so good on pop-ups that he does
these things a really quick two outs in
the blue jay fourth on only three
pitches now tay oscar hernandez
who grounded out his first time up he
swings at the first pitch and flares it
softly into right field for a base hit
he will stop it first and that's the
first knock for the blue jays tonight
runner at first two down there's a deep
drive to center engel already playing
deep moves back a couple more steps
makes a catch right in front of the
warning track
ground ball to short simeon to panic one
on to guerrero two as vaughn grounds
into a double play so that helps
the cause of hyun jin ryu 2 0 swung on
grounded to short it's been a busy night
for simeon there and he'll make the play
flawlessly to get engel
and the side is retired three to nothing
white sox at the end of four goriel
struck out his first time up five
strikeouts for kykel one two swinging a
miss cutter beat him
six strikeouts to tie a season high for
kykel so first and second two down
simeon has grounded out to short and
grounded out to third
one one line past a diving mendic into
center field rounding third and heading
home is panic he'll score espinal around
a third on an rbi single by simeon and
the blue jays are on the board now
trailing three to one
no wave and a miss and a fifth pump from
grand all on a changeup strikeout number
seven the jays get a run
[Applause]
three two and a ground ball base hit
into left center anderson the shortstop
was playing vladiover in the hole so a
leadoff base hit in the sixth
or strike three cutter again
his eighth strikeout tonight and it was
the perfectly placed cutter in on the
right-hander
to third
monkata
for round number two there's a double
play there joan thought that was the
third out yeah he absolutely lost track
of the out wow
and instead of being out of the inning
you've got guerrero at second base kykel
is yeah he's going what are you doing
and a ground ball into left-center field
for a base hit guerrero will come in to
score again anderson playing way in the
hole and the blue jays are within a run
there it is adams pops it up you've got
three white sox in the area it'll be
caught
by the center fielder engel
so the jays get one
they do strand a couple nine outs to go
against a very tough offensive club
on for the 23rd time a man on nobody out
seventh inning three two white sox
here's the pitch ground ball to short
could be two
and it will be a double play
anderson to mendic
to abreu and they turn it
way late on a breaking ball and evan
marshall is riled up
adam engel has bounced to the shortstop
twice
old for seven in his fourth game back
from the il another 2-2 on the way and a
drive in the air deep left center it
will go
that's his first hit of the season an
insurance home run
here in the seventh jose abreu who was
one for three tonight had an rbi double
way back in the first
hard hit through the left side that's a
long run for goriel maybe tim can get
home super joe's waving him around here
comes tim he is there it's five to two
tim's out of gas
the socks are up by three
a new pitcher coming in the ball game
and he's coming on with every intent to
pick up his 16th save and 18
opportunities liam hendricks 178 era 40
strikeouts just three watts 2-2
and the sox have won the series liam
hendricks gives everything again